ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show uh we are here a very good
friend uh director actor writer
Eli Roth thank you for coming thank you
for having me I know it's a rare
occasion it's a rare occasion
um for a guest on the show there's very
few and most of them are hated well I'm
a listener to the Pod so yeah I hate
when you have guests because I tune in
to listen to you rant so I know how
people feel hearing my voice yeah and
I'll just say this don't kill sharks
thanks Tim no but here's why I wanted to
have you want very rarely do I want to
talk to someone about something it's
true I spent a lot of time alone I drive
my car alone I swim in the ocean alone I
stare at people I go up and down PCH
it's actually very I don't mind Solitude
and I gather my thoughts and then I come
here and I say them very rarely do I
want to speak to anyone about anything
and hear or you know if I want to talk
to someone I'll just play something
they've said on YouTube and then when
I'm done with it I can just exit out
instead of having an actual conversation
but you
outside of the work we've done together
because we did just do a film together
which we will not speak about because we
are in a strike in solidarity with the
strike yes which will end soon we hope
we hope and we can get on and talk about
all that stuff because I have a lot to
share but we will not yes later on
months from now when the strike is over
and everyone is happy and the executives
and the writers are hand in hand if
you're having lunch with zazlov later so
if between that and your dinner with me
you know the breakfast with Bob backish
I think you should be able to solve this
I may be the secret weapon meaning like
and I've said this before why am I not
on a negotiating committee
I understand the way the executives live
where they eat what they enjoy what they
value and the writers don't because the
writers live in Echo Park in Silver Lake
and they're they're just it's a
different breed of human if you want to
call them that and I respect and love
them and I know that they need uh their
needs met
but they need to find a way to
communicate that to the denizens of
Beverly Hills of Malibu people that I
know and that I see and that I respect
and I like so we need to meet in the
middle but one thing one of the reasons
I wanted to have you on is that
somewhere along the line and I don't
know when your Instagram got completely
hijacked I thought you had been I
thought your Instagram had been uh
hacked hacked yeah I thought it was
hacked by environmentalists I didn't
know what was going on because I know
you as a director of films and an actor
and I'm like okay and you would ask me
you I auditioned for a thing you did a
bunch of times I didn't get it that's
okay it's by God's not a big deal I did
I think 40 auditions it's all right it's
fine and I think it was like I think you
were like we hired someone who's even
fatter and I was like God damn it all
right I don't know if I use those words
but it did serve as the audition for the
new one you know I basically was like
okay he can do it and that's good yeah
and I didn't I didn't make you
re-audition I wrote something that's for
you for the new one that's a good point
so I knew that from the first audition I
was like oh he's great and he can nail
it it just we needed a different type
for that role I like that and this was
like I'm gonna write something great for
you and well again we want to talk about
it we can't talk that's why I didn't
yeah but then I'm looking at your
Instagram and I'm I'm just seeing bloody
sharks bloody fish I'm seeing the
entrails of fish I'm seeing sharks that
are opened up and and you're you're
having this uh moment where it's all
about sharks and I and and what's
interesting about this is people have
breakdowns in a myriad of ways right in
Hollywood like people have all of these
CR like there's all kinds of ways to
lose it right lizzo was making people
eat bananas out of vaginas in Amsterdam
people just there they get to a certain
point they go and listen nobody's above
a break nobody
and I'm looking at this and I'm going is
everything okay can you communicate to
me why at some point in your life you
decided to care about vicious killing
machines that inhabit our oceans
well thank you for that lovely
introduction Tim I I agree I mean you
could say it's a mental breakdown but I
also have a somewhat manic personality
and obsessive which I think helps being
a director yeah I think you I'm like you
I'm totally alone I like to be in
solitude I like to write what I want
people to say and then control the
actions of what they do and then edit it
it's it's part of what I enjoy in
storytelling but I think I also love
sharks I grew up in Massachusetts I will
say this and you're a swimmer and an
ocean person I'd never seen a shark in
the ocean before have you
I have not seen a shark in the ocean so
everything we know about sharks came
from TV and movies because we had never
encountered one in the ocean because why
would you want to because a shark as far
as I was concerned was just going to eat
me so then I heard I someone asked me to
be part of Shark Week With the Show
shark after dark and they started saying
well you know we're killing 100 million
a year I'm like how's that possible they
go yeah we are it's for soup in China
and I go really that doesn't make sense
and I started talking to more activists
going is this thing real and they go yes
since 2000 it's a recent phenomenon they
serve it at weddings and uh the shark
trade has started then they stopped they
said well you can't take the fins
because that's cruel to throw them back
in so they started the shark liver oil
started and and all these kind of side
businesses started and I go well what
does Shark taste like they go well you
can't really eat it it's too toxic I go
what does shark fin soup taste like they
go it's nothing it's like fishing line
it's fingernail they have to flavor it
with chicken stock I'm like wait hang on
a second why do we need sharks like
what's the big deal and they go well
sharks are what keep the ocean healthy
they're like the doctors of the sea like
if you think you have a swimming pool
like imagine if you didn't have the
filter and all the scum started building
up on the top layer and there was
nothing to clean it like that's what
sharks function are so I went is this
true yeah because I've never once heard
and I'm not saying you're lying and I'm
not saying these people are lying and I
maybe you could look this up are sharks
the doctors of the ocean yes they are
I'll tell you why they are the oldest
Predators they're 400 million years old
without I know everyone's already tuning
out so I'll try and make it fun and
short 400 million years old they're
older than trees older than dinosaurs
they've evolved to basically be a
perfect Hunter where they'll only kill
what they can catch and they don't eat a
lot they'll eat once a month and they
eat the sick and dying fish so what
sharks do is they keep everything in
balance and they clean up the ocean so
which is interesting what it says here
as well as keeping the ocean food web
and balance sharks also play a pivotal
role in keeping populations that they
prey on genetically healthy as well as
removing disease and sickness from the
ocean hence the turn doctors I've never
heard this well that's there's a reason
yeah and there's a reason you're afraid
of them there's a reason you hate them
it's because the fishing industry is
making millions and millions and
millions of dollars off of their debt
but they also they also attack people 12
people a year more people more people
are killed by vending machines is that
truly like yes it is this is one of
these fake statistics about a fake
statistic how do you die from a vending
machine because your Zagnut bar gets to
get stuck and you pound the damn thing
going give me my candy bar and the thing
falls on you like 38 or 40 people a year
die from vending machines more people
are killed from armed three years oh my
God at least 37 deaths and 113 injuries
since 1978 that have resulted
oh but that's since 1978 that's not per
year that's what they're aware of a lot
of people aren't bragging about well it
says we're learning risk in the U.S of
dying from a shark bite is roughly one
to 250 million in contrast the yearly
risk of dying from a vending machine
accident is roughly one in 112 million
okay so this is the party line these are
the talking all right so it's basically
you you came in prepared with this well
I know this stuff from doing the reason
so I spent five years making a
documentary called Finn that is on it
aired during Shark Week it was on
Discovery plus then that sold to your
friend David zazlov so now it is on
stream on Max well no one cares more
about sharks than him right exactly well
the thing is nobody likes sharks because
they don't have faces they don't have
personalities they don't have vocal
cords it's not like when you say by the
way creepy
and here's the thing this is the way I
feel about sharks
I don't have a particular issue with
them but when when people say like we
have to live in balance with nature
okay but I mean let's I mean let's take
that to the extreme are we not going to
use uh bug spray are we not going to try
to limit uh the incursions of rodents
and things like that into our homes I do
think that at the end of the day we
should be
looking at sharks you know when we have
these seal populations that are out of
control they're nuts in where you come
from there's a there's a documentary
right now called uh
after the bite yes and it's incredibly
boring and a waste of everyone's time
but I watch it's you don't have to what
it's about is all these people from
Massachusetts with heinous accents uh
the water it's the worst but I grew up
with it but what it is is the seal
populations have gone nuts the sharks
are feeding on the seals there are more
sharks now than ever and it's created a
really dangerous situation for people
that want to enjoy the water and it's
become like the tough guy thing on the
internet to go hey you're living with
the sharks you're in their home you
better be uh you know aware of that
you're taking a risk and my thing is
like we need I think to really
not let sharks intimidate us and we need
to see them as a threat and counter that
threat the same way we would counter a
threat of China or our country you know
we are building up an Arsenal right now
to fight China in our defense department
we have trillions of dollars of money
being spent on weapon systems to
eventually counter China
should we not look at sharks the same
way should we not experiment with fences
at beaches electric fences sharks are
there they don't want anything to do
with us they don't 99 of the time
they're just they're there anyways they
don't want any they don't want any more
interaction with you than you want with
them what you should be afraid of is the
algae the acidic algae blooms look at
this this is interesting this is this
I'm also afraid of this look at look if
if you want to worry about sharks
closing a beach okay you can have shark
spotters they have in South America
someone looks and they go up there's a
shark people come out they go back if
the fin is up no they can you can I mean
you can see them you can they can have
drugs a video up of that person in Egypt
being mauled I want you to defend this
I'm not going to defend it to defend me
hang on a second okay let's talk about
the algae yes look up in Ventura County
this summer the beaches that were closed
because of acidic algae blooms Dolphins
were biting dolphins are washing up on
shore seals are washing up on shore last
week all the beaches in La were closed
because of bacteria this is this is when
they say the ocean is out of the balance
what the Sharks do and this is algae no
but they eat the fish they they keep the
grouper in check the grouper eat the
parrot fish the parrotfish eat the algae
so there's no sharks right and then you
have the grouper go crazy because
they're like well the police aren't
around let's eat all the parrotfish so
there's no parrot fish now so the algae
are like well hey we're great because
the grouper don't eat the algae they've
taken out the parrotfish the parrot so
now the algae spreads and it turns toxic
so animal life can't live but but it's
it's impossible to clean you can't fix
that there's no way that human beings
with our vast array of resources and
technology and science can fight the
algae without sharks no not yet I mean
we're talking about dumping chemicals in
the ocean the natural way to do it is
sharks right but we're pulling them out
of the water for nothing what's the
problem though this is mainly the
Chinese it's not that's the myth it's
that we're selling our fins everyone in
the world does it we just stopped
there's like a fin ban but it's legal to
kill sharks so that's why this thing
started the Alabama Bama deep sea
fishing rodeo which I was going to make
a post about I kept quiet and then I saw
what they did over the weekend two years
ago they allowed sharks so what they did
is these scientists Alabama deep sea
fishing Road it's the biggest kind of
fishing bloodbath in the United States
it's a rodeo where thousands of boats go
on a crazy fishing it's a show of
strength and two years ago from Humanity
they showed they they put they added one
guy who's a bear hunter added great
Hammerheads bull sharks tiger sharks and
people were so upset because you had
these beautiful magnificent apex
predators the hammerheads really don't
attack people so I say leave them alone
none of them attack people it's an
investigation it's an investigative bite
when you bite a sandwich are you
attacking it are you going okay but what
if it's a sandwich you don't know if
you're gonna like that's true you take a
bite and you're like if even if I'm
biting a sandwich that I don't know if
I'm gonna like the sandwiches let's say
let's say you go to Jada and you bite a
sandwich and you're like I don't know if
I want this set this the turkey and the
monster cheese maybe I have the roast
chicken and you take a bite and then you
know I don't like it I put it back but
you're not attacking it sharks attacked
five people over in the beginning of the
summer
yeah they bit people yeah now those
people are fine they were not fatal
bites yeah it's an investigation yeah I
mean how many does how many people die
from fentanyl I mean like there are a
lot of things more people die from bees
more people die from dogs it's not fun
you're not crusading on behalf of
fentanyl not yet right not yet I might
my next iteration yeah so this this does
and here's where I will throw you a bone
this seems a little [__] up well what
they did this year was not only but the
shark is tasty no but have you measured
it for mercury it's 35 times the
allowable amount of mercury in your body
so you have like Shark Girl Madison
there's project nakawi
this ocean Rams is a major problem I
know you do but I was amazing
and I don't well I don't like the
trolling of dude first of all is it not
disrespectful if we're gonna respect the
doctors of the sea to read to jump in
and redirect them and tap their nose and
if I did that to my doctor in Beverly
Hills he'd be upset if I'm like go that
way and I just touched his nose so I
don't know what ocean Ramsay is doing
she seems a bit sick well there look
ocean is big on education and is that
her real name that is her real name and
Ocean's been great with me and I think
that Ocean's main thing is of course
she'll defend her and all of us look
there are other people that feel people
like why are you touching sharks at all
that's correct there are plenty of
people that feel that is correct I will
completely acknowledge that but the
point is that in this Rodeo you had a
guy who killed a thousand pound tiger
shark Brett Rutledge look him up he's
the winner he won he won six thousand
dollars paid for by iHeartRadio so he
takes this apex predator they slice it
open and 25 babies come out the
fishermen so deep sea Guardians get all
these videos there and then the
fishermen send a video to deep sea
Guardians where they've taken the 25
dead babies and the mother and they did
a tick tock to the song baby shark and
that's where I was like you know what
it's on my Instagram yeah and that was
sent by the fishermen so I just said so
you basically have this Rodeo I will say
this I love um raycon earbuds because
they're like the other one but they're
better and they're less expensive and
you have
a 30-day happiness guarantee you really
can't lose
there are so many modes you talk you
know you have 32 hour battery life and
the modes you have awareness mode so
basically you can be aware of things
while you're listening to whatever
you're listening to music podcasts and
you can stay safe and it's the most
important thing I have in my life
the Recon earbuds earbuds
um and most people I know it's the most
important thing they have in their life
and it's the most important thing
they'll ever have
I'm in a safe house right now
um talking about them
create your own soundtrack with raycon
buy now Tim Dylan shortlisters can get
15 off their raycon order at
byraycon.com Jim that's byracon.com Tim
you get 15 off your order I mean what do
you deserve that no but you're getting
it because I'm telling them you know
what I mean like you you because you
know me you're getting it but you don't
deserve it you should pay full price for
raycon because it changes your life and
they're giving it to you for 15 off good
night now and and they get the size that
seems too far but they get the
scientists from Mississippi State
University on my Instagram uh it's like
Mississippi State uh Southern Alabama
University and then the deep sea fishing
rodeo put some precious going look
science is there now Noah which is the
body that's supposed to be overseeing
all this stuff Janet Coit at the head of
NOAA Fisheries says shark fishing is
sustainable my whole point is we can't
eat them it's too toxic to eat they're
not down ninety percent killing at least
100 million a year and I show this all
in the documentary it could be as high
as 270 million 30 000 an hour sharks
take 11 years to reach sexual maturity
they have like eight or nine pups like
they breed basically like humans so
they've killed this apex predator cut
out 25 babies made a tick tock with it
took the prize money from iHeartRadio
and nobody and all these scientists are
like shut up it's for science you don't
know what you're talking about and I'm
saying we have to completely end shark
fishing because now the beaches are
closed because the algae is spreading
it's a real problem and everyone is
looking at the activists going you guys
are crazy so what I've learned and you
want to know why I go crazy this is it a
lot of the the science labs they get
their money from the fishing industry
they're funded by them so they don't
want to speak out against it and the
ngos too the fishing industries so I'm a
film director I can go crazy is it
powerful asset to have in terms of
conservation one of the things that RFK
did was when RFK whose career was as an
environmentalist for a very long time
people don't realize that
um he went and he got you know the the
the fishermen and the hunters he didn't
go out and use words that were
politically divisive like global warming
he went out and said
let's get the hunters let's get the
fishermen don't you want clean rivers
yes don't you want uh you know forests
that are healthy and thriving yes okay
well here's how to do that and he you
know so I think the fishing industry can
play a vital role in conservation are we
against all fishing are you saying
absolutely not all fishing is bad no I
am not that's I completely agree it's an
extremist point of view it's very you
say that no one should have anything
there's two-thirds of the world shark is
bad what else are you looking to ban
just shark that's it just shark that's
it
um like honestly the the Sharks you
can't do anything with it anytime a
shark is out of the water well have you
ever seen when they do uh the jaw well
no no well that's nice yeah but also
have you ever seen like on a restaurant
when they do uh it's not quite Taxidermy
but I forget how they do it where they
take the shark and they you know they
make it into uh something into a wall
mount yeah here's the thing so much of
the sharks are killed by bycatch anyways
they're all getting caught in the Gill
Nets and the fishing there's and I do
think so they're not even pretty to look
at they're not yeah they're all ground
up they have no fins on them I mean look
you can't it's a pointless industry and
the reason people want to keep going is
because they want likes on Facebook so
I'm the one who's like I don't make my
money from the fishing industry I can
just be a voice and go why are we doing
this that's all I'm saying the whole
point of the doc is can't we just we 50
years ago the whole world got together
and goes why are we killing whales we
need to stop sharks will not be able to
never attack
it's it's except Moby Dick
right but Will's never attack and and
killer whales really don't attack people
except did you read in the heart of the
sea where the bull sperm whale Ram that
boat three times that's what inspired
Moby Dick before that was that was the
first sign of intelligence that book is
incredible because people thought whales
are Mindless monsters and the fact that
it stopped and turned around and rammed
Captain Pollard's bows twice and then it
happened to him again the guy got
Shipwrecked twice the book is insane the
people were started cousins when we
exempt sharks from criticism for their
behavior yes when we say that it's not
their fault that they killed somebody
and we are saying that you know we're
calling them Predators or apex predators
and I'm just saying like we should view
them potentially as a threat and they
should when they attack us shouldn't
they be punished
well I think that if you if you get
attacked by a shark then your chances
are probably better to win the lottery
or get struck by lightning I mean 12
people here's here's the thing Tim you
you are getting your wish right now yeah
what you wish for will happen to a shark
is happening 30 000 times per hour if
you want sharks to be punished what's
happening I'm not doing well but here's
the thing if if if we take away all
punishment
what happens you're telling me
you're saying you don't think if sharks
could they would come on land and kill
everyone if they wouldn't they don't
want to kill anyone they would figure if
they wanted to go on land they would
kill everyone they are you telling me
that you think sharks are like cuddly
people who are like I've been in the
water with them and I have cuddled with
sharks before when what a sand truck a
nurse shark no and what water tiger
shark
at first I I held it's me holding shark
in tonic that was a gray reef shark that
was in the Bahamas there was a shark who
had a hook in its mouth that they had
taken out that would follow me finally
in in French Polynesia I went in the
water I just with no chainmail with
nothing and they said just put on
flippers be careful don't Splash and
they threw Chum around me and I had like
a hundred lemon sharks around me and I
just sat still and they didn't care this
is a sexual thing people going in the
water with these shots it's what is
going on I wanted to know if they were
gonna bite me and they didn't and then I
went under the water with a tiger shark
for an hour and it was really cautious
and really aware and you know there was
someone with tuna fish behind me and I
fed them by hand and this thing didn't
go crazy just carefully glid buying it
and then I was in the water with great
whites you have to get in a cage with
Whites by law in Guadalupe and I saw
SEAL swimming around hanging on the back
of sharks fin and I was like and they
don't go after if they see us and when
you approach a tiger shark or Hammerhead
you have to underwater you have to be
very still hold your breath they get
scared of bubbles they they just like
are you a predator are you a prey you're
a large thing with arms I don't know
what that is I have to be very cautious
they take an hour before they come over
to you so by the time they get to you
you have very you have to breathe calm
because you have very little air left
because you only have an hour 75 minutes
of air underwater so I couldn't believe
basically everything I learned about
sharks was a lie from the media and the
reason they're doing it is because they
want people to be totally turned to
Blind Eye so they can keep killing them
so they can keep money so then why would
Spielberg make Jaws if it's a lie
except well he regrets it he apologized
for it is that what he said and Peter
eventually too it's one of the greatest
movies ever he said he's very sorry
about the damage across the Sharks I
don't blame Jaws I think it's the I
think it's the weddings I think that the
industry started but I I do think that
Peter benchley Well Jaws was a very big
component it was a fear of fear it
wasn't but it may be justifiable fear do
you know that because that was created
like there was that guy that got eaten
in Massachusetts there was a guy that
was eating in Egypt and we're supposed
to ignore this ten people get eaten on
land I'm not saying ignore it I'm saying
they are dangerous animals like let's
not pretend that there's cute cuddly
creatures look at that make that big if
you know how to go in the water yes I
mean this is horrible and this is the
poor guy this is your friend it's not
necessarily mine this is your friend
these are the people that you defend all
day these sharks I can defend them
because they don't have vocal cords
somebody needs to defend them I'm not
defending approach you know what they
would say horribly racist things they
would say anti-semitic things there's no
look at his face that's me that's me
with a little show is that really true
that's me right there on the right times
is writing about this
I can't get one review of my special
Jason cinnamon no by the way good to
millions of views on Netflix and and
they were writing an article about him
and a shark they trashed me they were
like oh did they oh my God they were
like the New York Times design I don't
even think they watched the movie they
were like Eli Roth torture porn blah
blah blah it's like I was like they
completely missed the point of it okay
so yeah so if you're very happy you want
to see me get trashed read the New York
Times review it's like they didn't watch
the movie or listen to anything I said
interesting but that's all right I mean
I I don't well you know what it is
you're a horror director you're known
for that and they think that you're just
kind of exploiting Gore and that's okay
but you I wasn't prepared for how much
you knew about this you're very well
versed on this well I have to be yeah
five years making the documentary and
there's a lot of people that put their
trust in me so and there's a lot of
people that are much smarter they're but
look trust me you you talk to the
biologists that are Dr Sean Powers Dr
Marcus dryman who were the two
scientists who endorsed the Alabama
culture they said the core of
environmentalism is a hatred of humanity
if I speak to those scientists they will
want to destroy all life on Earth to
protect animals well they they will they
will tell you that I'm crazy I'm an
extremist shark populations are fine if
you oh oh wait a minute if you ask
Janice so they don't they don't agree
with you the scientists no they think
we're crazy write their names down no no
because I do I've always respected
science but let's go I'm telling you go
on there they put up Noah put up a whole
Instagram defending shark tournaments
not even acknowledging the 25 because
they're bought and paid for exactly well
their Department of Commerce NOAA is
under the Department of Commerce because
they're more than paid for and you are
hated by the fishermen yes well I'm I'm
not anti-fisherman I'm just saying fish
whatever you want just leave the Sharks
alone that's all I'm saying does that
seem weird but but don't are you ever
concerned about and too much too many
sharks do you not have that fear at all
are you no you don't think they're I've
been in the one spot in the water the
shark Super Highway in fakarava in
Tahiti the only other person that was
out there was James Cameron in a boat
yeah and it's just like you go and you
do a drift dive when
where I was raised and I love and it's
my home and I love being there and we
banned the hunting of the deer well do
you know what happens now you're hunted
by the deer there's lots of deer is
there not something to be said for
balance
yeah but balance right now it's going to
take like about 25 years of not killing
sharks to get it even close to
rebounding if you stop uh fishing the
Sharks and shark bites go up to 100 a
year
and fatalities go up is that okay with
you
well yeah so your position is more dead
people less dead sharks well of course
but I don't believe that's going to
happen I think that what's going to
happen is with more sharks in the water
the oceans are going to be healthier
they've shown that reefs when you put
sharks in balances we all believe are
fine the re well if you've been
underwater with them and seeing the
dying reefs we also have pools right but
you would you what if we start to be in
pools what if we said ban your pool
filter and you let all like well my my
house manager
my pool got a very big algae bloom
because my house manager did not tend to
it and she was potentially I don't know
eating right and I had to have them come
in and they put a bunch of chemicals in
and within 48 hours it's fine right so
why are we not dumping chemicals in the
ocean to kill algae we are dumping
chemicals in the ocean make no mistake
about it it just has nothing to do with
algae interesting yeah like think about
the ocean as your pool and think about
that house manager as a shark if the
sharks are you know what I mean if you
had a better house manager that was more
of a shark and less of what would a
walrus I don't know a seal that would be
nice
I'm sorry I don't know your house
manager I'm not getting sued if you had
less of a like more of a shark less of a
seal I guess you can say seals yeah I
was disappointed with her behavior but
you know I didn't bite her I'm just
saying this there is a reflexive
position that most people have right now
it's this reactionary position where
they're always defending sharks and
they're always looking to
um you know attack human beings and it's
like well you were in the ocean it's
your fault well I think that's wrong I
think everyone without the other I think
that's crazy I mean I'm not trying to
listen I understand that the fishermen
in Alabama are being told this is great
you have the scientists to know going
there's no problem Go Fish them
everything's sustainable so when you're
told that by it's like the Milgram
experiments when the person says you can
shock which we I recreated for Discovery
and we saw like when someone says oh
they told me to do it when the
scientists are there and they condone it
people believe the scientists because
why wouldn't you they're reputable
scientists they're not like shady of
course these are top scientists that are
going populations are fine I don't know
where their money's coming from that's a
question yeah but the problem is people
go crazy next thing you know they're
ripping babies out of pregnancy and
making tick tocks but they're doing it
because they're like it's for science
guys and they're like haha they hung a
bull shark from the American flag now if
you're a veteran is that what you want
like endangered sharks hanging from a
flag in Alabama and everyone going
woohoo like something's wrong that's not
okay so when I see the environment I was
just going like why are we doing that
you can't eat it there's it's completely
useful and now we're gonna get the
outside get them or throw them out
they all got thrown out and in fact in
New York they have the Block Island
there's there's shark fishing
tournaments there were two of them I
think it was Block Island Star Island
fishing they're now finding all the
carcasses of the the juvenile ones
because you have to throw back the
underweight ones so all like the kid
sharks that they didn't bring in that
they didn't report are all just rotting
in the bottom of the ocean the whole
thing is it's like and then we criticize
China but we're the ones killing sharks
at home why can't we clean up our back
can we all have fulfilled lives without
killing sharks that's all I'm asking is
this one thing that we can all do and
it's not going to come from me it's got
to come from the kids of the fishermen
someone in Mississippi someone in
Alabama has to go you know what Dad can
you just not kill sharks I know you love
fishing but we can't eat them and you
just throw them back and all you're
doing is making tick tocks with them
you're making tick tocks with dead
sharks that's the only reason you're
pulling them out of the water or getting
prize money can you just not do that is
that possible can we have fulfilled
lives without dead sharks well you know
I I certainly think that's an idea and I
see this bull shark here
um that was hung from the American flag
and
I I do understand what you're saying but
I also understand that that Public
Safety is important when people are
swimming in the ocean
and we have to you know realize that
sharks are coming closer to the beaches
now they're swimming in they've always
been there well but but is it you know
this is I think an increasing
uh danger to people and that people have
to be very aware of these animals and
they have to be very aware of you know
the the potential for them to be violent
and deadly and like there is this thing
where but that's like saying that is
there's Bears vicious I'm against those
people
like people fetishize vicious animals
and they think they're cute and cuddly
this happens all the time there was that
uh documentary but that guy that hung
out with bears and then guess what
Grizzly Man he got eaten they got eaten
by a bird okay now your friend uh ocean
ran stressing whatever her name is ocean
Ramsay eventually statistically she's
going to get ripped to shreds by one of
these tiger sharks on YouTube reels or
Instagram reels YouTube shorts I don't
want it to happen I'm saying what she's
doing is incredibly dangerous and she's
trolling a a an apex predator
so to me I just think that
they should be viewed as Predators they
you said when a shark comes into contact
with humans they go predator or prey
I think is is it wrong that humans look
at sharks as Predators or prey if that's
how they size up us is it wrong that
that's how we are sizing up them we are
not on either of their food chain
they're not on our food chain and we're
not on their menu they just they don't
know like they take a bite and they
don't we're like two bony and fleshy
like when you see a tiny little bird or
a sparrow you're not like oh let me take
a bite it's like right maybe it was a
big roast Americans are getting fatter
they are Americans are now resembling
marine life it's true in an alarming
rate in an alarming rate many Americans
are indistinguishable from sea lions in
the water this is very true this is a
fact
sharks will stop seeing Americans as
bony and flashing and start seeing them
as what they are
kind of large marine animals that will
provide sustenance for shark but the
idea okay so let's say you win and we
now eliminate all sharks I don't want to
eliminate all sharks I've suggested
electric fences I've suggested poisoning
some the ones that are bad I've
suggested clubbing seals because the
seals on the beach are the reason that
we have more sharks now you talk about
algae blooms the reason that we have
more sharks is because we have more
seals you used to be able to Club a seal
on the beach they banned that they got
rid of the seal clubbing used to be able
to go and you would go boom you're done
you wouldn't always kill it but you
would just go boom and then they would
know oh this isn't Fun and then they
would leave and then the shark because
we have more seals now than ever and in
Massachusetts they're saying this and
these shark conservation freaks come out
and go don't worry about it it's okay
and they have to remind them they go the
job of of this is Public Safety it's not
to protect sharks it's to protect people
we have a Constitution now when you when
you were able to remove the seal but now
you can't remove the seals you can't
touch seals can't make the seals
uncomfortable so then sharks eat the
seals it makes it unsafe for everybody
the beach is getting closed all the time
and you have to understand that the
parents who lost their child in the
water in Massachusetts who is surfing
have a right to be angry at the sharks
so many people running online businesses
right now but they really don't know
what to do and here's what because it's
the back office and people are like but
how are people going to get what I ship
to them
and how am I going to ship things to
them without losing my mind
and what you do is you use shipstation
because it is one service that allows
you to interface with all the major
shipping carriers USPS FedEx the PO all
the stuff and what you basically do is
you are using shipstation as a way to
you know
like automate all of your shipping tasks
so that you can keep track of who gets
what so you can devote all of your
energy to the origination of new
business being Creative Marketing you
know generating leads doing all that
stuff you know you don't need to be
worrying about
did the Johnson family get the package
we ship no that's not your job your job
is to make the magic let ship station
handle the back office you need to make
the magic
and everyone has magic inside of them
and very few people get to it because
they're always concerned with shipping
this is why most people fail in the
world because they're like how do I ship
it where will it go well I'll tell you
ship station go to shipstation.com and
use code Tim Dylan today sign up for
your free 60-day trial shipstation.com
Tim Dylan you're free 60-day trial
meaning that for 60 days which is two
months you do not pay anything you
remember House of Cards where he would
go CLA
Francis ah
um that show was about politics and
about
um hacking
and and
at the end one of the guys hacked into
the NSA and because they wanted the
election to be won by uh Frank and
Claire Underwood
so what I'm telling you right now is you
should use expressvpn because it
prevents Hackers from stealing your data
and governments from spying on you and
private uh data mining operations from
taking your data and selling it to
people
expressvpn scrambles your IP address so
it's like you're anywhere and this
allows you to basically you know be
protected on the internet you got to
protect yourself
uh Claire it was a great show and they
should have let him finish it even
though season five has a pretty fine
ending expressvpn
.com Tim Dillon that's
ex-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com Tim Dylan for three
months free with a one-year package
three months free with a one year
package that's insane that's a quarter
of the Year free with a one-year package
expressvpn.com Tim Dylan you want to
protect yourself while you're on the
internet you do not want these people
coming after you taking your stuff you
know it's not fair and it's not right
so many things are wrong this is one of
those things that can be right you can
right the wrongs and have the Justice go
to expressvpn.com Tim Dillon for justice
of course I mean that's I'm not inhuman
if I had a child that got eaten by a
shark of course I'd be upset you can't
blame you can't say well it's your fault
and I do agree with you that you can't
save God I think do they have a God
these sharks have a God you know do you
know that in Hawaii the spirit of your
ancestor goes into a shark that's why
they I'm a little I've had enough of
them by the way I've had enough of them
I know everyone's spiritual over there
and then you go over there everyone's
600 pounds and on math what happened to
the spirituality by the way you leave
the resort okay you leave the Four
Seasons in Maui there's spirituality
goes out the window because there's a
gun in your mouth and they're taking
your luggage okay so I've had enough
well the how about more rain dances and
less gun in the mouth so but that person
dies and their Spirit goes into a shark
so wouldn't you want that person who put
the gun in your mouth be inside a shark
this idea that like Hawaii is some great
spiritual place and it's just tourists
getting knives to their throats
um listen I understand what you're
saying you have to understand what I'm
saying if I own a house in Southampton
or Malibu or Palm Beach I should be able
to float in the water without thinking
of shrive paid enough money to so that
these sharks should know this guy should
not be touched and In fairness I haven't
had a problem in those three places and
I've been in the water a lot that's what
I'm saying is that none of us you know
99.9 of us will never have a shark
encounter we're not supposed to but I
think we need you need to have healthy
respect for them but I think that we
need to protect you who would win a
shark versus a polar bear
oh that's a good probably a shark
interesting yeah sharks are Ambush
Predators right you know you wouldn't
even know the shark is going to get you
you'd be floating and then you're either
gonna live or not they move they'll take
off like a rocket and just bite you but
this is what I'm saying it's just it's
weird to me like why do we see
people that live with very uh you know
they adopt these animals right you see a
guy living with a a tiger you go that
guy's nuts but when we see these people
going into the water
and touching sharks or giving sharks
cute nicknames
does this not raise is this not a red
flag to me it's a symptom that it's just
a reaction to What has been presented
out there before if everyone had just
been like sharks are important we need
them leave them alone stay out of the
way don't swim at night don't like these
are the times when sharks are feeding we
have people can spot them from drones
going okay there's a shark here you guys
watch out like if we had a healthy
respect for them the way that a lot of
the surfing Community does
um then I think we wouldn't have to have
sex
surfing Community Jonah Hill used those
words Surf and Community they were
disgusting that and they're disgusting
now those two words to me are vile uh
because there are Surfers I think with
many different views but I get it I get
it respect the oceans respect to sharks
blah blah blah blah
um it we may get to a point where pools
are the new oceans it might happen it
might get to that point where literally
like it or not here's the thing whatever
we say in this room people are going to
keep killing sharks because as long as
you're making money from doing it well I
don't make a dollar from it we don't nor
do I nor do I get any money from this
but that's why you know FedEx is still
shipping sharks GNC is still selling
shark products but people can go to this
are they good bonds what about the shark
oil what is that terrible we tested it
in the lab in the documentary what does
it do for you nothing it causes
inflammation it was started by a guy who
wrote a book called sharks don't get
cancer which is a lie sharks do get
cancer and then two weeks later he
started a shark cartilage pill thing
because he's like well they're killing
all the fins and taking the oil anyways
Image Google Image shark fin soup let's
because let's see because you try it I
try it in the in the movie I ate it and
it's not good and they have a gelatin
version that's identical and I went to
China what about New England clam
chowder is amazing dude I love clam
chatting so are you gonna go on a
crusade next to protect the clams no I'm
not going to save the clams I will
don't you think tuna are going hey man
uh because the vegans
are gonna say well Eli Roth seems to
really love sharks and maybe it's
because they're Stars sharks are stars
yeah so they get a lot of attention so
if you make a documentary about tuna no
one cares but I would I heard some
things about tuna while I was making
this someone told me that there's a
certain corporation that is trying to
kill every tuna in the ocean and freeze
it and stockpile it so they can own it
have you ever gotten the criticism from
vegans that you're not going far enough
all the time all the time what is your
response to that why pick sharks why not
salmon why not tuna what about octopus I
was at avra the other night in Beverly
Hills and the manager there who treated
me very nicely and I will be returning
although I was trying to eat healthy and
they sent me 19 desserts for free that
wasn't great but I do like the
restaurant they sent me free uh uh uh
you know on the house they sent me an
octopus uh like a appetizer yeah and
don't they have a movie where my octopus
friend right and isn't that some freak
that's friends with an octopus once you
see it it's like it's too it's too
upsetting like I had a pet pig I can't
eat Park anymore once you know Eli you
know
first of all you can you can eat bacon
you can eat pork it's phenomenal
um the reality of the situation is most
of America I'm sorry not America
most of the a lot of the world is
starving it may not be most but a lot of
them are starving it's true and a lot of
them would eat anything they could get I
know and this idea that we are sitting
at the top of the food chain in this
incredibly privileged country lecturing
people like the Chinese a lot of them
have to eat dogs that's what it is
they're poor and you know what they're
eating dogs and I've always supported
their right to do that even when people
are get mad at me because people are are
poor and if I was in a poor city in
America and someone was eating a dog I
would not yell at them if I was in
I don't want to say a city name but
let's just say uh uh Levittown Long
Island and a family was eating a dog
because that's all they had I'd go hey I
get like don't you see that to people
around the world it seems so privileged
to sit on this perch and be high and
mighty and say oh this guy is the luxury
of worrying about fish like for example
when you go in on the Safari in Africa
um
you know there there are people that get
offended by you know the hunting there
that you know what happens but a lot of
people will tell you that game hunting
actually supports the environment yes
because it actually allows investment in
areas that badly need it it promotes uh
the the uh a necessity to have the
species propagated so it doesn't go
extinct and a lot of those animals are
going into Villages and eating people
and so it's funny to me when it's like
somebody like you or ocean Ramsay on
your yachts in the ocean and you're
having little you're having little tea
parties with the sharks because you're
the elites but then there's other people
that are getting eaten by sharks and I'm
worried about those people well I was I
was very careful about that Tim and
that's one of the reasons that over the
course of the movie I go to everyone in
the country with sort of No Agenda I
Don't lecture anyone I go out with a
shark fisherman and I try to understand
why they're doing it how they're doing
it how they can feed because what I've
seen is that in the Bahamas says one
shark dead is basically sells for about
thirty dollars one shark alive can bring
in 250 000 in shark tourism in dive
tourism so there's actually there's
actually a gold mine so so there's
actually more money keeping the sharks
alive much more money so so I worked
with a woman named Reggie Domingo we go
to the fishermen and there's there's two
beaches one called Cabo Puma one called
Los freireless and then where is this in
Mexico in Baja California you're always
out of the country oh well I go around a
little odd it's not odd you're
constantly uh like on the land country
but look I sat down we have beaches here
in America where you grew up how about
you visit them I did and I went to the
shark tournament in Massachusetts in
Newburyport it's crazy so I talked to
everybody and I don't come in I don't I
know how they see me I know they're
going to see me as privilege and there's
some Hollywood director I was like let
me just go and just turn the camera on
and let them say their side of the story
because I think that you can't tell
people what to do I think you can only
lay out the facts and go is there a
better solution than this can we just
stop doing this what what would the
benefits be and the answer really is you
look at shark girl Madison she's helping
in Indonesia the dive tourism helped the
fishermen we should be helping the
fishermen turn their businesses into
dive tourism because we have literally
two beaches side by side one has tourism
they're all thriving and one is killing
sharks and it's everything's dying so my
feeling was like I know I'm going to be
mocked I know everyone's going to go at
me I sat down with the shark traders in
China they'd never gone on camera before
and I was like I just need to understand
they're like and the guy said the same
to me he goes do you know what weed in
China do you know where all the pig's
feet go they go to China we eat
everything people are and I listened and
they're starving and I hear them and
it's a great point and I go I understand
that guys it's our Salient point that
we're gonna be out of sharks in 10 years
anyways if we don't stop now they're not
going to be able to repopulate I'm just
saying that I think we in the Western
World in the First World
um
have a a privilege and we don't realize
that food is really to many people
around the world of luxury and
like if you're a a young person that is
not hungry I'm sorry that is hungry and
you're in one of these countries and
you're look like you're working hard at
school all day and you're waiting for
that bowl of shark fin soup when you get
home and you go I work hard all day at
school and then you're driving a
rickshaw a literal Rickshaw through the
mountains with your panda friend and
you're going up hills and up and down
the hills and then you get to this
lovely little rustic little Chinese kind
of like bamboo it's very it's kind of
well appointed and you and your panda
friend get out and mom goes hey and
here's the shark fin soup that's
someone's culture
so to me
what you're suggesting is like someone
goes oh I have a culture but it doesn't
matter because you want them instead of
that to go through McDonald's get 15
cheeseburgers and like you know like
start like I don't know vaping by the
mall but they're like no no no no no no
we have a culture too and it's eating
this soup I asked them about that it
actually started in the 1960s there was
a story that one of the Emperors in the
year 800 said I want to eat a shark
because that's the strongest animal and
I want to be stronger than that so then
in the 1960s the restaurants the hotels
were like what if we served it as a
gimmick and just to get people to stay
here and have their weddings here and
then in 2000 China really started
getting money or 90s took off it became
a really expensive item but the problem
with the soup is that nobody likes it
because it tastes like nothing it's
actually fishing wire so they have to
put chicken stock in pork stock and they
have to scrub it with bleach now the
bleach they scrub it with is the same
stuff you clean your toilet with it has
neurotoxins the bleach does not come out
they have have to scrub it bleach it
dehydrate it rehydrate and it only just
feels like if you bit your fingernail
that's exactly what it tastes like so
fairness so so I'm describing 85 of
American fast food exactly as well
there's a lot there's plastic in the
yoga mats at Subway I know I'm sorry
there's yoga mat plastic in the bread
yoga yeah the yoga mats all of my yoga
at Subway but you know what I mean like
like you're making good points but then
they will turn around and they will go
you're serving people plastic they can
they can say it but here's the thing the
Young Generation in China I I asked them
I go what what they don't want it at
their wedding because the parents are
doing it to show off and I said that you
know I said with you I don't listen to
the younger generation because they
don't believe in Tradition they don't
believe in values they're many of them
have been raised on the internet they're
sick
and if you're gonna have a shark fin
soup a traditional shark fin soup at the
wedding
and you know if you're having food that
has actually no flavor and causes
impotence in brain damage which it does
with the neurotoxins in the fin and and
to even get it to taste like anything
you have to flavor it with either but
it's delicacy and it is a flax it's it's
a flex but they but what we realized
fake there it's not 50. dummies but we
realized fake if you have an expensive
bowl of mushroom soup or lobster soup
people are just as happy and we talked
to everybody so the young people in
China are over this are over and the
older people are just like we just want
to show off give something expensive and
treat our guests well so a lot of people
destroy every tradition that's ever
existed on the planet like this is my
this is a fake tradition it's it was a
marketing gimmick it was never a
tradition it's not like oh by the way
the Pharaoh Islands you know they kill
them if you ever sat down with one of
these fishermen and have they really
opened your mind
you know when you sit down with a
fisherman like a yeah a a hearty kind of
old salt from Massachusetts who's like
you know the Sharks must be eating yeah
but really though has any has anybody
opened your mind to the necessity of
this is there do you see any of the
arguments from the other side at all the
only thing I can see is that in a place
like Indonesia uh they're starving and
eating shark because there's a lack of
protein that's that's a serious issue
because Indonesia but what I've seen
mainly is that it's like the mafia is
very involved in Spain there's they're a
huge Spain is the number one exporter of
Finns it's a completely useless trade
there's not a single person where I sat
down I was like and that's why you see
me in the documentary talk and I go
crazy I'm like but I don't understand it
like the soup has no flavor it caught it
has neurotoxins none of the health stuff
like what is it and then it's like oh
everyone's just making money from
killing them so why stop it that's
really the answer well I mean listen at
the end of the day it's it it's
certainly you have an opinion and I
think that it's valid and I think you've
done research into it
um and I think that like there's me is
there not a happy medium
oh can we not meet in the middle what is
the middle though the middle would be
viewing sharks as violent Predators yes
protecting ourselves against them by
means of well I don't know but
but you've been in the water your whole
life you've never even seen one a sand
shark once swam into me and was
disgusted don't you think that's racist
isn't that the definition of racism as
you've heard things about you have
actually no experience whatsoever with
sharks none everything is from what
someone has told you and what you've
read in the news you've never
experienced one you've been in the water
your whole life and yet you still
believe this That's How Strong the media
is don't you see the brainwashing that's
been the last 40 years that's what the
fishing industry wants they like us to
be terrified and angry and petrified of
them instead of saying going we need
them respect them protect them but let's
figure out a way
I'm only sometimes on a plane if I have
nothing to do
and I have the Wi-Fi I will watch shark
attacks like a lot of people
and
we all watch plane crashes which is
actually kind of ironic and fun to do in
a plane but I'll watch shark attacks
because I want to know what's going on
and I want to know what I'm up against
and this idea that sharks Eli are not
violent when they are apex predators is
crazy but that's not my position my
position is please don't kill them we
need them okay but also how about please
don't kill us two sharks well there's a
lot of other things that guy in Egypt
why is the tiger shark eating him I
don't know
tiger shark but the tiger sharks it's a
tragedy it's a tragedy people are going
to die like we can't protect we can't
child proof the world we can't you know
what about a gate no I'm literally
saying what about if they tried people
tried it it doesn't work why because you
can't build it in the ocean the ocean
moves you can't like build something
that sits in the ocean that keeps sharks
out which we have drones that watch the
Sharks and can we send threatening
things down like not not just not just
we just there's a horn they do shark
spotters they just there's a shark
people move out five minutes late shark
passes most of the time the sharks are
there swimming with us
we never know it because they don't want
they're afraid of interaction I'm
telling you they only go after things
they know they're going to eat and they
don't eat that off and they're pelagic
they wander the globe eating the sick
and dying fish that's what they want and
so when we're splashing around that's
mimicking that like when a fish is
injured well I don't like splashing it
out into it a lot anyway because it's
very it's kind of like low rent Behavior
well you know when you have to float
kind of like you know
uh you know like you just kind of like
just be quiet I don't like a lot of
splashing I don't like a lot of loud
music on the beach I don't like a lot of
fast food you know like a certain type
of beach I like a couple of women in
white linens for a quiet woman don't go
in the ocean it's a little gross and the
men will go into the children or the the
housekeeper will bring the children in
but the women sit there a little white
linen on the beach reading a novel I so
there's certain type of beaches that I
don't go to I mean and God forbid and
God help us we know a lot of what's
going on in the beaches right now it's
crazy
um but I'm just saying you know I've
always been a person who believes that
human beings are a special and unique
thing
I know that about you no I believe that
and would you ban smoking I mean you're
an advocate of smoking well not always
but I think there's times when a
cigarette will make a situation more
livable
um uh but no I I I I wouldn't ban
smoking what I would say to people is
you know
I believe human beings are special and
unique and I believe they have dominion
over the animals and the beasts a lot of
people do and I and I don't even believe
that
necessarily in a theological Christian
way I believe in it in a we are smarter
than them we are sharper and we have
been able to do things like make things
like drive-throughs and nuclear weapons
and uh all-inclusive resorts and things
that people may not like but
they're nice did you know that great
white sharks speak with mouth gaping
they do this a lot
these little jaw movements and move
their fins and is that speaking that's
how they communicate and what do they
say well they go down in the bottom they
decide who's going to go up to breach
they have an order they discuss it
amongst themselves you'll never see two
sharks breach on a seal now can you
speak in mouth gaping and fin movements
no but a lot of people I grew up with
can well so a lot of those people decide
through mouth gaping and fin movements
who's going to talk to what girl and
who's going to get in what car exactly
so there's a lot of human beings that
behave in a certain way I'm just saying
I I here's what I say and this is maybe
the the the the resolution let's all
just lighten up right right because
you're making these very depressing
things about oh there's all the killing
and the shark let's lighten up the
Spanish Mafia let's let's all have some
wine and relax let's not go here and
tell everyone how to live that's my only
problem you like I go let's not am I out
there killing a shark with a knife no
but I'm very much let's Live and Let
Live let's let people around the world
do the things they want and if it's your
culture to have the shark fin soup at
the wedding I don't know if it's my job
as a western American to tell you how to
live I believe that we all share a
planet but the sharks are pelagic they
they roam the globe so they're taking
your sharks out of your way as much as
it's like it's it's a problem that
affects all of us I don't want to tell
anyone how to live I know no one's going
to listen to me but when I see them
making the tick tocks with the 25 dead
babies in my gut I have to say tasteless
and they're hanging it from an American
flag that's taste that's what I said I
was like what are we doing no that's
wrong and then I heard rados paying for
it kill the universe
with two and they're celebrating it and
so how can I not say something it's
about it's just I listen I agree with
you in that case what's your that's your
favorite animal as a shark pretty much
let's be honest it is I love dogs too
but yeah sure what's your second
favorite well sharks and dogs
sharks and dogs is that the next
documentary the people eating dogs in
China oh no the next documentary is
gonna be something far more sick that I
can't even talk about because that's
another before we let you go am I the
greatest actor that's ever lived well I
can't speak in specifics but I will say
you are a brilliant actor and I and I'd
say and I say it's better than Leo or
Clooney and if I did the roles they did
the movies would be better because it
would be less about sex enough with the
sex all the time it because people can
focus on the movie everybody's asexual I
mean with we're not promoting something
specifically why is Timothy Charlemagne
everything when I can also do it for a
fraction of the cost I think if you
change your name to Timothy Dylan May or
something but it's just he's all the
time he's befuddled and Confused
let me in and I'm more direct and it
hits a little harder can I tell you
something in my opinion if I was to call
me by your name you know how homophobic
people would be
you should be Willy Wonka that would be
the champion
with the kids the kids just getting
stuck like
sharks on that set and eat them all I
mean that's just you it's sad for me to
see a lot of these franchises things I
grew up with being destroyed uh for
whatever reason or you know reinvented
in ways that I I can't uh co-sign and
and but I do appreciate you coming on I
do appreciate this I I know that you've
swayed me a little bit here where I do
understand now where you're coming from
with the algae the algae is bad look up
Google algae bloom Venture County I
don't care about venturiken but I do but
these beaches were closed this summer
because they're like out of control
acidic I don't like that and I do and
that's because we're killing all the
sharks and they can kill them in Alabama
and it's going to affect the sharks in
California like the Sharks move around
they don't just sit in one state so
that's what I'm saying is like can we
just as a practice is there a way to
make them live on land like is there any
way that they could live on land I
looked into it I used to work there's no
way right but could they they it's like
it's like the Dolphins I mean it's like
the the orcas you can't you can but part
of the problem with them is that they're
in the water all the time and no one
really like it's not you don't interact
like if they were on land a little bit
we're not supposed to see them they
don't have faces they don't have
emotions so people are like the only
time you see it is when there's a bite
what are they going to do
the shark did nothing ever why don't
they have faces well they've evolved
that way they here before there are they
are our last dinosaurs I know there's
some dinosaurs in the movie industry but
these are real dinosaurs for real and
we're wiping them be here forever they
should no there were five mass
extinctions we're currently in the sixth
they will not survive this now at the
rate we're killing her hedges keep
saying that Chris Hedges that we're in
the sixth message how do we black what
does that mean well we're killing
everything which we know but like the
bug I mean pick your cause they're
people that talk about the bugs that the
bugs are dying the people oh no here we
go more bugs but that's great but the
sharks aren't the sharks are not going
to make it we're killing them too fast
and there's too much against them and at
a certain point do you know how buggy it
is when you go certain places it's very
buggy so what are we doing I don't know
well we all want to live in the
Brazilian Amazon do we all want to live
in in bug tense I'm sorry about
civilization I'm sorry about Western
Civilization I'm sorry this russoian you
know third world thing we're all doing I
I know it's kind of fun to do in Silver
Lake with your hat but the reality is
civilizations is actually a great
accomplishment of humanity it is and
animals have their own thing but we got
to figure out a way to kind of deal with
it and they're going to deal with us
well I think that anytime you take a
position defending something you're
thrown in the category of crazy
extremists right and all I'm saying is
can we all live happy and fulfilled
lives without rewarding for killing
sharks and everyone says well it's just
a few sharks in Alabama but it sends the
message to children that these are
prizes that this is fun and that this is
a whole culture well that listen yeah
can we not do that fish for food but
well the Gilgo Beach guy didn't kill any
sharks
right
he didn't
but you know again Long Island for the
win
he's not out there killing sharks he's
not going to kill any more from jail
people want to because everyone's gonna
agree with you when because my fans are
soft so when they see this they're gonna
you you've made a lot of sense and
you've come in here with Statistics and
and biology and all this crap and people
are going to say that I'm throwing out
kind of superstition and fear but I
think both of those things have a
tremendous value
and that's a great point to come maybe
end on is like don't you think it's a
little hypocritical that you make people
afraid for a living like hostile I'm
afraid of Eastern Europe now for no
reason none Eastern Europe's not like
that although it is a little but like
this thing
when you made hostile you're making a
movie about people that are kidnapping
and torturing and murdering people and
it's a secret Club of Elites where they
can visit this place and and and kill a
person it's all before anyone knew
anything about Epstein's eyes yeah well
it's all before we all knew that was
kind of we all know that it was real you
made us scared of of these these
communities billionaires that wanted to
cut people's eyes out but you were right
but I was correct you were correct I was
on to something so maybe these uh Peter
benchley is right or maybe I'm correct
with Finn that we gotta you know now we
gotta do this for the Sharks I also
thought it was kind of perfect because
if you if you're an environmentalist
you're going to get a certain crowd but
if I make horror movies people will know
maybe I'll give it a chance maybe I'll
listen to what he has to say and they
don't have to agree sharks are going to
get killed no matter what we do but at
least I'm the CR I'll be the crazy
extremist that puts out the idea and
maybe moves the you know the Overton
window a little so when you hear it
again next year they're like it wasn't
Eli talking disaster but I have a friend
who does like think he's going to get
eaten by a shark all the time and I do
want to say to this person nothing
special will ever happen to you nothing
good or bad will ever happen to you so
don't worry about it like my friend's
like well there was a juvenile white
shark in Manhattan Beach I go you will
never make the news for anything not for
one thing nothing no one will ever care
about you at all so tell people where
they can see this documentary where they
can support your efforts thank you I
mean Finn it's on HBO Max or Discovery
plus it's called Finn and you can go on
my Instagram page or actually a great
page is shark allies is a really good
one but I would say watch watch Finn on
HBO Max and look at my Instagram and I
tag everybody and and if you want my
point of view watch guy in Egypt eaten
by shark that's on YouTube you can find
it on Tick Tock they keep Banning it but
it keeps popping up you can watch that
that's my argument in a nutshell in a
few minutes a guy yelling daddy as the
sharks eat him uh timdellaccomedy.com
American royalty Tour on sale now and
let's hope you have a resolution here
are you Optimum Mystic this is going to
be resolved soon I think everybody wants
it resolved and I think all parties are
and I think that you know the Tim
dylanization of Hollywood needs to start
um very soon and uh well the reality is
that I want to I won't really want to be
able to come back here and talk about
your work because I think you are you
know I think you're something special
and I I can't wait for the world to go
it's very nice of you and I will say
that in the reality there are a lot of
people hurting it's been a tough time
yeah there's a lot of people all the dry
cleaning businesses all the side
businesses the restaurant it's so
painful [__] tough right there's just
restaurant workers that are are saying
like nobody's eating out nobody's doing
lunches and stuff anymore and it's like
it is an economy it is fun to [__] on uh
Hollywood because it's worth [__] on
but like there is an economy of people
that you don't see that are really
affected by this you know what I mean
yeah uh it's not just the CEOs we all
feel bad for them because the names are
being dragged through the mud and so we
all feel bad for Zazzle
obviously the first thought we have is
like are they okay yeah well they can't
they can't even use their names at
restaurants anymore no it's tough It's
hard but the reality is they can all
right
um and but that's our first thought but
then also much further down the line
people that may not be as sympathetic
like restaurant workers or unemployed
writers still should get a little bit of
our sympathy I think you know I think a
tiny bit of it should be reserved for
people that are like I've missed a
mortgage payment but still the vast
majority of it should be to people that
are being yelled at during College
commencement speeches it is very
embarrassing I thought it's very funny
if zazlov had again just take it out of
gun instead of shooting wildly in the
ground I mean it's just funny but no one
has any fun anymore Eli Roth support
everything he does save the Sharks blah
blah blah
um we'll see everybody on patreon.com
thank you bye